with these now what are public data sets
that you can download off the net that
have been vetted people have been
classified according to their
intellectual capabilities Etc now you
can s begin to show that certain and
this is one of the papers that we're
just submitting certain brain structure
organization sizes and tracks between
them are appear to be correlated with
certain kinds of intelligence or certain
kinds of abilities and you know we're
not the only ones doing it by not by far
but I haven't seen many papers yet that
are taking it the same approach that we
are with these automated segmentations